va disposer d'un capital quand j'en
aurais envie pour voyager me faire
plaisir et il l'a très bien compris
il m'a proposé un placement rentable
disponibles et en plus je bénéficie
d'avantagés fiscaux
j'en suis très contente et bien sûr j'en
parle autour de moi l'epargne de france
de nom de l'avenir à votre argent je
vous redis donc ce chiffre que je vous
annonçais tout à l'heure juste à la fin
du journal
quatre cent mille interventions
d'appendicite en lui offrant chaque
année vous me dites que ces trois à cinq
fois plus que dans le reste de l'europe
et aux états unis est une association
l'association française de chirurgie
s'est demandé mais est ce que ray pas
par hasard des opérations abusive la
réponse est alors la réponse on va la
trouver à travers une étude qu'a
justement commenter cette association
française de chirurgie dans un récent
congrès dans cette étude ont été passés
au crible mille interventions de
l'appendicite sur ces 1000 interventions
il y avait à peu près cent quatre
patients pour lesquels vraiment il y
avait une appendicite grave indiscutable
370 patients une appendicite non graves
mais absolument indiscutable aussi 330
patient car il n'a pas dit si tu qu'elle
aime discutable c'est à dire que au
moment où ils ont été opérés on ne
savait pas quelle serait l'évolution de
leurs problèmes si on allait vers une
guérison ou vers une aggravation mais
qu'ils ont été quand même opérer et une
centaine de patients pour lesquels la
fin dit c'était complètement normal
alors moi l'idée c'est une erreur de la
part de
des praticiens qui se sont trompés ou
alors c'est un abus parce que ça faisait
gagner des sous on ne peut pas parler
d'erreur dans un premier temps vous
allez voir pourquoi en fait une des
raisons pour lesquelles il ya autant
d'opérations de l'appendicite en france
et que les chirurgiens ont été éduqués
d'une certaine manière au cours de leurs
études ils n'ont pas on ne leur a pas
appris ce fameux probable proverbe dans
le doute abstiens toi mais au contraire
dans le doute au père nous fait l'école
française alors que dans d'autres pays
on leur dit au contraire maintenant le
doute et bien on attend un petit peu on
surveille on hospitalise éventuellement
le patient et on attend donc autre
raison évidemment qu'on ne peut pas ne
pas évoquer c'est le problème financier
parce que quand on est hospitalisé dans
le privé le chirurgien est payé à l'acte
donc plus il multiplie les actes plus il
multiplie les honoraires mais évidemment
on a envie de penser quand même que ces
pratiques là sont très peu changé
ça arrive ayez déjà faire un centre
comme ça oui on en a la justice en
médaillon est tout à fait tout à fait
pour certaines interventions maintenant
autre débat soulevé par le problème de
l'appendicite c'est la manière d'opérer
il y actuellement deux techniques la
chirurgie traditionnelle en la chirurgie
l'échangé traditionnel qu'est ce qui se
passait bien tout simplement hors garde
sur ce petit schéma le chirurgien va
faire une incision dans l'abdomen
à ce niveau là en bas à droite pour
retirer l'appendice de façon tout à fait
classique intervention vraiment très
très courante une des interventions les
plus fréquentes en france
maintenant les chirurgiens ont à leur
disposition une nouvelle technique plus
récente qu'on appelle la coelioscopie et
qui consiste à opérer presque sans
ouvrir l'abdomen c'est à dire que le
chirurgien la pratique et de minuscules
d'incision et va se servir d'autres
instruments les instruments de ce type
là ce sont des petits ciseaux des
petites pinces des micros instruments en
quelque sorte et il va opérer donc avec
des instruments vraiment minuscule on va
faire coulisser à travers des tubes dans
l'abdomen croise un volant et on ne perd
donc avec mais vraiment des petits
instruments vous voyez de quelques
milles
m simplement un peu le soleil rouge et
un style on va faire bouger voilà et il
suffit de compter avec des vrais mangane
ou accro tu veux pas dit ce qu'on a vu
la wii et vous avez là on rentre on peut
rentrer cidre abdomen bien sûr et le
chirurgien va surveiller l'intervention
à travers un écran de télévision alors
avantage de la coelioscopie
c'est que évidemment moins on incise -
les muscles de l'abdomen sont touchés et
moins les douleurs consécutives à
l'intervention doit être important donc
le malade va - moins souffrir dont il va
être hospitalisé un petit peu moins que
lors d'une chirurgie traditionnelle
il va éventuellement aussi avoir un
arrêt de travail - moins longs et les
cicatrices et en plus petites évidemment
elles vont être plus esthétique
alors maintenant on n'a pas assez de
recul pour dire voilà telle technique
est meilleur que tu as l'autre il faut
attendre un petit peu le débat reste
encore ouvert mais voilà si on va être
opéré de l'appendicite on s'affole pas
l'une ou l'autre les techniques sont
baltes les travers merci nous avons
trouvé l'équipe de reporter bilon de
télématin bob de singles et son camarade
sky man alors ils utilisent toujours le
même subterfuge sont avec leur et leur
équipe de télévision de france 2
peut-être qu'ils disent pas france 2
d'ailleurs il dit voyant de son petit
ticket pour une petite émission n'a pas
beaucoup de budget et on voudrait faire
une enquête sur deux sur les chiens tous
à ce que ça vous enduire est de faire
semblant que tenir un chien en laisse et
au besoin vous allez tenir bon camarade
en laisse vous allez voir à quel point
ça peut marcher oui c'est complètement
surréaliste on a besoin de faire
rencontrer sur deux chihuahuas y en a
pâti wawa donc on a un comédien qui va
jouer le chihuahua donc madame nous
sommes ici pour vous interroger sur
votre chien est ce que est ce que vous
le nourrissez
souvent oui assez souvent disent on vous
donne deux repas par jour matin et puis
on voit souvent le matin était un soir
prochain qui vaut de l'argent je crois
oui bah oui je sais plus combien je vais
acheter mais il faut pas vous l'avez
acheté dans mon c pour ça rouleau comme
la hausse à wimille et la cia c'est cher
il est nerveux
ça dépend bon là il est un peu nerveux
parce qu'il tire vieille fille nick
neave il ya ici
doucement voilà mais il est nerveux ça
décoiffe faut pas l'énerver disons et
vous faites coucher dans votre lit ou
pas des fois donc on a vraiment qui
touche la sanie chez eux
voilà vous fait courir à wissant simrad
monsieur dick mortels monsieur comment
c'était quoi la question vous le faites
coréen oui j'ai fait courir oui bah des
fois je l'emmène aux voix et puis pour
qu'ils courent beaucoup à bach bien là
bien là doucement
voilà
oui pour beaucoup il court beaucoup
parce qu'il a besoin ceux des planches
et se dépenser pardon et ce qui l'a
beaucoup d'énergie à revendre il ose
tout alors il faut expliquer aussi pour
la crédibilité c'est qu'on leur dit
voilà vous serez cadre est comme ça là
ce que vous voyez là l'argent du bon ben
ça va je vais faire semblant de tenir
ils sont aimables nous avons trouvé
françoise xenakis pour parler de livres
maintenant mardi dernier franchement que
nous avions esquissé le début du
commencement d'une pro nique mais c'est
bien comme ça comme ça on peut revenir
c'était sûr anam christophe bataille ce
jeune homme de 21 ans qui a écrit un
petit livre de 91 pages maintenant il a
un recueil de presse qui doit dépasser
150 pages ça commence à faire beaucoup
en philo et c'est rentable au kilo mais
depuis annie ernaux les éditeurs aux
éditer des petits livres avant c'était
absolument défendu un manuscrit de 90
pages on me disait c'est une nouvelle
message et une nouvelle non c'est un
très beau texte
mais attention c'est un très beau texte
qui raconte à l'époque de louis saez un
petit prince qui vient apporter une
supplique de son père qui est roi en
amont au vietnam et le oui c'est ça
commence à mal aller alors la page est
très belle et c'est ça qui réconfortent
les françaises quoi enfin cannes fut
présenté au roi l'empereur entra dans la
salle du trône
il donna louis saez un parchemin usé par
les sels marins au cachet du vietnam
son père y présenter sa requête avec
lenteur le roi lui le texte il soupira
regarde à l'enfant tous deux s'ennuyer
pareillement louis saez délaissa le
protocole ai dit mon enfant mon royaume
n'a plus sa richesse d'antan votre pays
est loin le mieux ça gigote pop souffle
mais celui de france mais met davantage
et venez à vous à nous si vous le
désirez mais la france n'ira pas au
vietnam
et le petit moeurs de solitude de froid
et gronder par un prêtre
parce qu'il se réconforte sur le sein du
nih nous nous et ils meurent de froid il
ne retombe jamais mais à cette époque
quelques prête parts dans ce vietnam
mais comme c'est la révolution le bateau
mais près d'un an arrivent et ils sont
sans nouvelles de leurs évêché et c'est
une dérive beaucoup sont massacrés et il
en reste deux un homme une femme cela va
de soi et ils vont dans les villages et
au fur et à mesure il reste toujours
profondément catholique mais la vie
autour d'eux les prend et peu à peu la
fin du livre
ils s'aiment et c'est joli c'est joli
mais je crois que tout le monde s'est
jeté sur ce livre de christophe bataille
parce qu'il a 21 ans parce que ça
raconte une histoire révolue et que
c'est merveilleusement écrit ça rassure
les français enfin jeune homme de 21 ans
qui écrit le très joli français on avait
2 ou non mais vous savez que les
romanciers français maintenant la
littérature avance donc entre les
onomatopées de certains écrivains
analphabètes réécrit par d'autres pas
plus cultivé qui sont effectivement de
mauvais livres
on a quand même des écrivains qui avance
en littérature ça c'est un merveilleux
recul ça relève du prix de l'académie
france un vous donneriez vous à un oui
cela dit avec une histoire pareille mais
l'histoire est belle oui il n'aurait pu
en faire six cents pages
oui oui mais bon savoir-faire course est
un talentueux
j'émets des réserves sur la non
progression mais c'est intéressant je
suis sans voix et plein en allusion
c'est important j'ai pas compris ce que
vous voyez je dis ça comme ça toni
morrison
ouais on perd pas de temps mort pas du
tout arrangée grand prix nobel de
littérature une femme noire qui écrit
des romans extraordinaire mais vraiment
il faut les lire s'ils sont tous chez
christian bourgois il faut il faut tous
les prendre
et alors là je voudrais quand même piqué
une colère c'est que oui oui vu que là
ce sont des conférences qu'elle a donnée
dans les universités américaines
sur comment les américains qui sont pas
vieux les américains ont découvert leur
identité littéraire à travers melville
thuan peau et mes ailes alors tous les
noms américains anglais sont cités là
christian bourgois adore la culture
anglaise ça fait très chaud pour les
franches et de lire ça mais elle toni
morrison elle commence son livre sur un
travail sur marie cardinal way sur les
mots pour le dire
alors elle élève elle se donne la peine
de commencer son livre sur marie
cardinal et nous français qui achetons
ce livre aux américains qui ne nous
lisent pas parce qu'ils disent qu'on est
mauvais ce qui est souvent dray mais qui
n'est pas toujours vrai dont une
américaine comme toni morrison est là
lui marie cardinal et elle a travaillé
sur le texte de marie karim djoudi c'est
le gâteau longueur non exactement c'est
le catalan bay et nous parce que ça
ferait pas assez chic d'avoir une
française sur le quatre roues la gomme
mais c'était que l'as surtout marié car
design mais oui parce que sans problème
ou de mambo bon alors qu'est ce que
c'est que cette publicité à l'envers ce
snobisme à rebours alors cela c'est
quand même lui qui l'a publié il faut
pas trop oui mais pourquoi est ce qu'il
a honte qu'elle parle ça lui couper son
truc ça faisait pas tout tout américain
pour les snobs qui vont a livré un
nombre record de moi non c'est pas
correct
à part ça appartient maintenant c'est
remarquable n'ont pas cessé la colère de
françoise donc d'une pépite colère
voulions une grosse colère novembre
alors qu'on vienne pas nous parler du
casting des acteurs n'y a pas un autre
mot si distribution d eau qui vont à
l'elysée pour dire qu une franche
d'attribution
ça vous regarde et le type tout ce
malheur à qui danse hors de la ronde et
je reviendrai marre des suspects comme
ils disent en français mais vous pouvez
déjà allé le chercher
ludwick harris c'est le nom non aride ou
des carrés très bien merci beaucoup
c'est l'heure de la météo merci
françoise mai prochain lors de la météo
maintenant avec nathalie rihouet
des mots pour le dire nathalie a
beaucoup de mots à vous dire moi un seul
fait les frais ce matin
oui a fait un temps froid anticyclonique
sec et qui va s'éclaircir
progressivement car il est vrai que pour
le moment ce sont les nuages qui domine
et puis double au fil des heures et bien
le soleil va s'imposer sur la bretagne
sur la normandie le nord et la picardie
de base apparitions du soleil également
des pays de loire jusqu'à la champagne
aux ardennes en passant par le bassin
parisien sur la façade aquitaine
on peut tout de même parler sur ces
régions date en voit les effets partout
ailleurs après les nuages de ce matin
quelques éclaircies qui resteront tout
de même assez rare vont se manifester
il y aura encore un régime d'averses qui
va se prolonger sur les régions
méditerranéennes
en revanche le soleil devrait dominer en
corse en ce qui concerne les
températures pour cet après midi elles
sont toujours fraîches pour la saison
vous l'avez compris les températures
assez ailleurs de 4 à 5 degrés aux
normales saisonnières il fera entre 9 et
13 degrés sur la moitié nord et de 12 à
22 degrés sur la moitié sud pour demain
ce sera à peu près le même site de temps
à nos petits cyclone donc un temps sec
froid et un peu plus ensoleillé
darty le contrat de confiance
bon il est pas là 8h30 et si on se
disant voir dans l'île dont on doit se
dire au revoir on se retrouve demain moi
je serai là avec toute l'équipe de
télématin mais on termine avec
l'actualité et laurence piquet roi
bonjour à tous un coup dur pour ceux qui
prennent l'avion dans la région
parisienne l'aéroport de roissy et
paralysé yannick letranchant tous les
avions sont cloués au sol ce matin c'est
bien oui laurence et roissy la pagaille
et les passagers en carafe c'est un
raccourci c'est un raccourci pardon mais
il faut savoir que tous les vols air
france au départ de roissy sont
supprimés même chose pour les arrivées
air france pour les arrivées air inter
prévus à roissy ils seront déroutés dans
la mesure du possible sur orly ce sera
donc le programme de la journée aucun
vol air france à roissy renseignez vous
pour les départs 05 que 05 11 55 pour
les arrivées 05 05 15 55 bon courage à
toutes et à tous on en aura besoin merci
annick edouard balladur à la recherche
d'un minimum d'accord national sur le
dossier du gatt fin des consultations
tout à l'heure valéry giscard d'estaing
sera reçue à l'hôtel matignon
hier les politiques les patrons les
syndicalistes et les artistes ont défilé
dans le bureau du premier ministre ces
derniers ont demandé la protection de la
production française
sur les 40 personnalités auditionnées on
trouve toute une gamme de nuances du non
catégorique oui mais raymond barre quant
à lui demande une trêve de deux mois
afin que le gouvernement puisse négocier
sur tous les sujets les agriculteurs
sont invités à rechercher des solutions
durant les deux prochains mois on sait
qu'il n'est ni le gat ni la pac
alors pour protester contre la chute des
cours les producteurs de porcs vont à
nouveau manifesté leur colère durant la
nuit 200 d'entre eux ont investi la sous
préfecture de guingamp
il était également devant la préfecture
de saint brieuc durant la nuit à
l'étranger benazir buttho a été élu ce
matin premier ministre du pakistan par
l'assemblée nationale
retour sur la scène politique après
trois ans d'absence son parti était
arrivé en tête des élections
législatives
à huit jours enfin en haïti l'embargo
pétrolier militaire des nations unies
est entrée en vigueur ce matin
une mesure qui vise à contraindre les
chefs militaires à accepter le retour du
président en exil jean bertrand aristide
si les états unis recours à la force
sera haussée drass le chef de la junte
promet du sang et des larmes neuf
navires patrouille en ce moment au large
de l'île la france de son côté envoie
une frégate sur place voilà vous savez
presque tous je vous donne rendez-vous
demain matin dès 6h30
très belle journée à tous bonjour voici
une super machine à coudre
elle est si petit que vous pouvez la
tenir dans une main mais tout aussi
efficace qu'une machine traditionnelle
maintenant prouver raccommoder vous même
pantalon ou jupe avec un minimum
d'expérience de pourrait utiliser cette
machine sans effort et cela partout
pratique et confortable elle est si
légère et facile à utiliser que même un
enfant poudre avec penser aux gammes
temple en un clin d'oeil vous pouvez
raccommoder rivaux ou canapés et
pourquoi ne pas réaliser vous même vos
rugissements de carnaval cette machine à
coudre ici compact qu elle se glisse
dans n'importe quel tiroir ou sac de
voyage
téléphoner sans attendre et
renseignez-vous vite
c'est la radio je fais de la télé j'ai
pas beaucoup de temps virginie lemoine
en vidéo dans la collection juste pour
rire avec france 2
l'événement courtemanche smaïn et ifs
ansari
alors soyez là
si vous aimez les belges des sorts
d'humour ce jour jamais osé [ __ ] j'ai
fait ça n'arrive qu'une fois trois buts
en encaisse un ben tu me connais mal de
stars mais les voleurs que tu nous
emmerdes l'a89 à l'arrêt moi oui
ssamedi arrêté à 50 sur france 2
bonjour à tous trafic aérien est
fortement perturbé depuis hier soir à
l'aéroport de roissy à la suite d'une
grève du personnel d'air france
tous les vols de la compagnie nationale
ont été annulés au départ comme à
l'arrivée
à l'origine de cette décision les
manifestations organisées par les
grévistes qui occupent depuis hier matin
une partie des pistes de l'aéroport pour
protester contre les nouvelles
suppressions d'emplois 4 milles d'ici à
la fin de l'année prochaine une
manifestation est également prévue ce
matin à orly en bretagne les producteurs
de porcs ont été aussi voulu montrer
leur colère face à une chute des cours
sans précédent
cette nuit des incidents se sont
produits à saint brieuc et à guingamp
olivier les usa à saint brieuc 500
producteurs mécontents talus mais des se
lancer des projectiles et couché les
grilles de la direction départementale
de l'agriculture
les policiers ont utilisé des grenades
lacrymogènes pour disperser des
manifestants la préfecture de
saint-brieuc a fait état d'un blessé
parmi les forces de l'ordre à guingamp
150 manifestants ont investi la sous
préfecture
aucune victime n'a été signalée les
producteurs de porc breton protestent
contre une baisse des cours vertigineuse
une baisse liée selon les spécialistes à
une surproduction européenne
le cours du porc a chuté lundi à 6
francs 80 l'an dernier à la même époque
le port coûtait en moyenne plus de 11
francs
les analystes prévoient une baisse plus
importante encore al'approche des fêtes
de la toussaint les syndicats agricoles
demandent donc une augmentation des
aides à l'exportation et un allègement
de la dette
les producteurs les plus fragiles à
matignon edouard balladur termine
aujourd'hui ses consultations sur le
gâteau son d'année visiteurs sera valéry
giscard d'estaing le président de l'udf
est attendu vers midi dans le bureau du
premier ministre
un assassinat et un attentat à la
voiture piégée ce matin à madrid la
victime est un général de l'armée de
l'air espagnole
il a été abattu par un commando d'hommes
armés et cagoulés dans une rue du centre
ville
quant à l'explosion de la voiture piégée
elle s'est produite devant le bâtiment
de l'institut national de l'industrie
mais apparemment il n'y aurait que des
dégâts matériels dans les deux cas il
pourrait s'agir d'une opération de letea
l'organisation indépendantiste basque
et puis à bayonne au pays basque
français un homme a été grièvement
blessé ce matin dans l'explosion de sa
voiture
pour l'instant on
or s'il s'agit d'un attentat ou d'un
accident lié à la manipulation d'un
explosif au pakistan benazir butto et à
nouveau premier ministre après la courte
victoire de son parti aux dernières
élections législatives
elle a été élue ce matin par les députés
à la tête du gouvernement trois ans
après avoir été écarté du pouvoir
benazir buttho qui fut la première femme
à diriger un état musulman moderne doit
prêter serment cet après midi avant de
former un gouvernement de coalition
on haïti premier jour aujourd'hui du
blocus décidé samedi par le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu pour obliger le
gouvernement militaire de port au prince
a accepté le retour du président
aristide légalement élu avant d'être
chassé du pouvoir par le général c'est
grâce sur ordre de bill clinton
les six navires américains qui
patrouille au large se sont rapprochés
des côtes pour être bien en vue des
autorités et de la population haïtienne
et puis à rome federico fellini le grand
cinéaste italien et luttent toujours
contre la mort dans une chambre
d'hôpital à la suite d'un double arrêt
cardiaque et respiratoire qui l'a plongé
dimanche soir dans le coma
voilà fin de ce flash quotidien
accessibles aux sourds ou malentendants
bonne fin de matinée sur france 2
your brillance avec performance
hydratantes mais je vous font le plein
de santé la preuve ils sont éclatantes
bouillant
performance et de latence de l'oréal ya
six ans extrême du cheveu le sucre si le
goût des bons moments quand il joue au
keno gilbert et ses collègues quant à
principe chacun donne son avis il s'en
tire nathb fait d'accord commun
aujourd'hui mes camarades et moi même
avons décidé de jouer les numéros pour
500 mille francs
pas vrai les gars ont nettoyé de tous
est numéro 1 gilbert est cette nuit
et vous comment jouez vous aujourd'hui
il existe un dentifrice y évolue et qui
continue d'agir business
après le passage le nouveau coq est
totale la protection anti bactéries qui
vous protège vraiment entre les pros
sage si il vous protège contre la plaque
et le tartre pendant le brossage vif
pendant que vous travaillez
ils aident à lutter contre les caries
pendant le score il lutte même contre
les problèmes de gencives pour tous où
dormait nouvelles protections longue
durée colgate total le brossage est
tellement bon qu'il agit entre le
brossage
que dites vous des céréales avec une
telle variété de fruits oui c'est génial
ses pairs et ses pépites si croustillant
non ce mieux que ça selon moi j'ai un
extrait 1 go + xtrac extra en général la
logique de l'assureur n'est pas celle
assurée aux mutuelles du mans assurances
par définition la logique de l'assureur
est celle de la sueur
mutuelles du mans assurances une autre
logique de l'assurance vie d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui lankaise devant le siège de
la cuisine et le retour au rayon frais
mais c'est
essayez une peugeot 306 et vous
constaterez que rares très rares sont
les voitures qui va peut-être
comportement motif de joe 306 essence ou
diesel
piaf l'émotion d'une voix inoubliable
enfin en vidéo l'unique récital filmé et
enregistré en public
edith piaf une vidéocassette france 2
avec europe 1 et s'il ya un second père
je voulais te donner sa merci à épée
faloci histoire de dire sur les 110
millions de préservatifs vendus chaque
année il y en a un pour moi quoi
oui mais a que 25 % des gens qui s'en
sert 36 chez les jeunes et j'en fais pas
si grand père les gens les mieux
informés écoutez elle vous venez
d'acheter un nouveau système pour votre
micro ordinateurs etes-vous sûr qu'il
soit le grumeau fiable c'était faire
plusieurs choses à la fois au bout le
plus rapide mais ce nouvel os de version
2.1 difficile d'émettre plus de plus
ce soir 20h50 pour les boursiers
d'harrison ford melanie griffith par la
conquête de wall street
sigourney weaver n'a qu'à bien se tenir
dans working girl
le rêve américain devient réalité 22h45
bas les masques sida ça n'arrive pas
qu'aux autres
mireille dumas recueille les témoignages
de personnes touchées par une maladie
qui nous concerne tous
00h25 dans la fièvre des défilés michel
field reçoit christian lacroix pour un
cercle de minuit très stylée bonne
soirée sur france 2
bonjour merci d'être avec nous un rapide
coup d'oeil sur les titres de cette
édition orly et roissy paralysée par la
grève la plupart des vols d'air france
sont annulés ce matin les grévistes
protestent contre le plan de
restructuration en avant première voici
le nouveau billet de 50 francs
il est l effigie de saint-exupéry et le
petit prince est là également nous le
regarderons à la loupe
ankama mes opérations de pompage débute
aujourd'hui mais sur place on est
confronté à un autre problème épineux
celui des moustiques après avoir déferlé
sur les états unis les dinosaures
débarque en france jurassic park le
dernier film de steven spielberg et sur
les écrans demain le phénomène
jurassique dépasse le simple cadre du
cinéma le film et les produits dérivés
devraient rapporter tenez vous bien 6
milliards de francs
la couleur du temps pour les orties
viennent toujours des nuages si j'ai
bien compris et nathalie il faut monter
à 900 mètres d'altitude pour trouver le
soleil effectivement ri si vous
bénéficiez d'un petit avion pour monter
à 200 mètres d'altitude et pour trouver
le soleil là tout ira bien cela vit en
dessous ce sont les nuages bas qui
domine les nuages bas et brouillards car
nous subissons des conditions
anticycloniques favorable donc à
l'information des ces nuages bas donc
cet après midi la pression générale sur
une impression de grisaille et aura même
quelques averses qui vont se manifester
sur le littoral méditerranéen
quelques éclaircies vont revenir sur le
sud ouest quant aux températures très
basses pour la saison à s'échelonneront
entre 10 et 22 degrés merci à tout à
l'heure le conflit opposant la direction
et les syndicats d'air france se durcit
depuis hier soir l'aéroport de roissy et
paralysé ce matin la compagnie a dû
suspendre ses vols sur l'aéroport d'orly
à la suite d'une manifestation
les grévistes protestent contre le plan
de restructuration qui prévoit 4000
suppressions d'emplois avant la fin 94
on commence par la situation à roissy
avec yannick letranchant les passagers
c'est le cas de le dire sont prises au
piège
est-ce que point nous expliquer les
raisons pour lesquelles vous êtes à
petit aujourd'hui
la graine voici la pagaille et les
passagers en carafe la marche à pied est
obligatoire avant de prendre son avion
encore faut-il qu'il y est un avion tous
les vols air france sont supprimés au
départ et à l'arrivée de roissy
c'est le programme de la journée les
vols air inter départ et arrivée prévue
à roissy sont transférés à orly dans la
mesure du possible
embarquement immédiat pour la galère je
pars à nice et pour du travail et où je
suis obligé de tout changer si si j'ai
pas l'avion
j'essaye de partir son jeune âge je vais
voir si je peux trouver une solution
claire france il est annulé
c'est pas chez canadian alors je ne sais
pas comment ça parle ça mc g star ce
matin les accès routiers à roissy sont
restés bloqués durant quelques heures
les personnels au sol qui soit de la
maintenance du fret ou des escales ont
aussi paralysé les pistes ils protestent
contre le dernier plan social le
troisième depuis 1991
4000 suppressions d'emplois sont prévues
d'ici à la fin 1994
ils sont en train de tout nous prendre
ça devient la catastrophe il pourra dire
passe tout à air inter bon si le
gouvernement a décidé de braver la
compagnie les agents ne seront pas
d'accord ils sont prêts à tout pour
éviter ce genre de choses on nous
massacre notre compagnie part d une
déréglementation violente par des vols
qui sont donnés air inter par la libérer
la libéralisation du transport aérien
même entre compagnies aériennes
françaises et nous ne pouvons pas
l'accepter
les manifestants un bon millier ont
envahi depuis une heure la piste
principale de l'aéroport roissy ya
bloquant ainsi une partie des vols
d'internationaux
après une semaine d'actions sporadiques
la mobilisation semble décoller